- Imagine instead of white,
gray, or black rooftops
you look out over a sea of green
that stretches to the horizon.
That's really what our
vision looks like long term.
We're Up Top Acres and
we grow food on roofs.
We convert underutilized spaces
into vibrant productive farmland and
we use this farmland to try to drive
the conversation to create better cities.
To turn them from concrete jungles
into living, breathing ecosystems.
- 80% of the US population
lives in cities right now,
and we are shipping food 1,500 miles
on average from farm to table.
- So instead of miles driven we're
trying to measure the
distance our produce travels
in flights of stairs.
- It's a lot more than
just growing food on roofs.
It's also about how can we create the city
of the future and to
make it a reality now.
The end goal is really just
to create a better city.
This year we're shooting to have about 70%
of produce grown on the roofs distributed
to the buildings that
those farms are on top of.
And then the other 30% will go to
the farmers market and
then also some restaurants
in the neighborhood.
I wanted to start Up Top Acres
because I wanted to combine the two things
that I really like which is farming
and living in the city and I think
that all three of us deep down
really wanted to try to make our city
that we grew up in,
that we love truly a better place.
We're going to deliver to a market cafe
called Little Red Fox.
They're some of our oldest
clients and we love them.
- Up Top Acres is one of the local vendors
that we work with.
Having ultra fresh produce
is a lot more exciting
for the customers just to be able
to know that this was grown downtown
and got delivered this morning.
So we're here on harvest day and we're
about to harvest some of
our all star lettuce mix.
And it's gonna be distributed
to our CSA members
down in the lobby of the
building later today.
- I'm gonna go cook.
- See ya, enjoy!
- Thank you!
- Everyone benefits when
we're installing the system.
You're reducing energy cost,
you're reducing storm water runoff,
you have access to fresh food and
it's a benefit for the
surrounding community
because these are unique natural spaces
that don't usually exist in cities
but we're right on top of a metro station.
One of the biggest things
that sticks with me
is whenever anyone comes up onto the roof
they always shave the
same sort of reaction.
It's why isn't this being
done on every building?
When I hear that that's
really what drives me
is let's make this a reality on every
new building that we're putting up.